let's bring in Ian Rapoport nfl.com
insider and Ian let me start with the
jet such what are the Jets doing the
Jets are listening and if you don't know
then you definitely heard Joe Douglas
the general manager say it about ten
times from the podium yesterday and you
know it's funny because it's sort of a
you know it's a little bit of a
controversial thing now especially when
Jamal Adams came out and said you know
that the GM lied and that they were
shopping and my understanding is that is
not true the Jets could not go out and
shop
Jamal Adams they didn't go out and say
this is a guy we want to trade by
contrast the Atlanta Falcons very much
wanted to trade Vic Beasley and his
hefty salary and his own production they
shocked him it didn't happen but they
wanted to trade him the Jets are
basically doing the opposite what
they're doing is we will listen to any
offer except for maybe Donald and Quinn
and Williams we would be open to a huge
blockbuster trade if someone gives us
something like the Jaguars got for Jalen
Ramsey we would move one of the faces of
our franchise but only if we get that
kind of deal so they held out from what
I'm told for a first-round pick and two
seconds that is what the Jets wanted for
Jamal Adams that is a massive haul of
picks they didn't get it so they didn't
trade him but he's frustrated because
his name did come up in trade talks but
this is kind of the other side of having
a GM that's open minded yeah but you
have two guys who were protected and
everything everybody else was up for
grabs for the jet so they are they
trying to tank now no they're just
trying to build and Jamal Adams is a
great player he's I mean he's a great
player he's a dynamic player he's a
leader he also wasn't drafted by our GM
your coach wasn't there when he was
picked I think there's just a different
sort of attachment when obviously Donald
and Quinton Williams were either because
the GM came in late but I think there's
a different attachment when you have a
GM who took these players or some GM was
coming in and just taking over yep the
other thing is the Jets need to build an
offensive line they need receivers they
need they need a lot really they need a
lot of things so
sacrificing one player for three Premier
picks is a way to build a football team
and although it gets everybody upset it
has proven successful in the past that
that is a way you can build your team
yeah but then I like Le'Veon Bell was
there a market for lay beyond Bell to be
traded not really no and you know it's
funny because I actually heard that on
Monday that someone had called you know
cuz I think everyone knows that Joe
Douglas the new Jets GM is pretty open
minded so they got a couple calls on lay
down Bell on Monday from what I
understand there weren't offers and
whatever inquiries weren't serious so
you know as I kind of go through like
what to report what not to report I knew
it wasn't happening I knew it wasn't
serious so I was like you know what not
gonna make a big deal but if it's
literally never happening it's like you
know when someone calls about a great
player hey would you trade us you know
Odell whatever I don't know that didn't
happen by the way but I'm just saying
you sort of choose not to report it
because nothing's really gonna happen
and that was my situation with Lady Anne
I don't think it got close he's due
thirteen fully guaranteed next year I
don't think anyone's traded for that
contract best trade rumor you heard
I appreciated the Redskins calling and
asking if the Browns would trade him
Denzel Ward for trend Williams and he's
a shot down corner he's one of the best
young players in football you know
someone trying to trade for him it's
pretty great people calling the Texas on
DeAndre Hopkins nothing I heard about a
couple of weeks ago was was pretty great
I actually had a conversation with a
Texas person about that and the response
I got was will you stop calling these
the N like 11 catches last week not
training DeAndre Hopkins leave me alone
you know I was like okay alright great I
haven't have a great day and I was
literally that was the conversation was
it a good day for the Redskins the Trent
Williams decided to show up even though
he's not gonna play I don't know for
sure that he's not going to play I know
the Redskins had a conversation with him
yesterday and came out thinking that
there's a good chance he's going to
practice if he passes physical so I saw
the reports
I had not confirmed that he was refusing
to play it was brought up to me as a
possibility like maybe he's going to do
a sort of Jalen Ramsey with his back
injury or something like that but I
think you know he also would probably
want to get paid and if you're not if
you don't play you don't really get
there not once you show up there's not a
lot of options for not playing I mean
you can fake an injury which I feel like
everybody would see through that other
than that if you simply once you show up
if you stop showing up
you basically have no recourse I mean
the other thing is the Redskins are
gonna try to trade him in the offseason
I really do think they will get better
than the second-round pick they were
offered yesterday they might get a one
in say February or March
the Patriots kicked the tires on anybody
tied in another wide receiver and
offensive lineman yeah definitely did
they tried for a couple of tight ends I
know they were interested in power
Eifert and OJ Howard I know they were
too interested in couple receivers I
think and honestly like a lot of people
when the 49ers traded for Manuel Sanders
a lot of people looked at the receivers
and said like who could be trade for
because they figured they were dumping
one they didn't end up doing it but I
know there was interest the two problems
with the Patriots one they didn't have
any money I mean they did have money but
they didn't have any caps faced Antonio
Brown is still tying up a lot of their
calf space so they didn't they just
didn't have really any room the other
thing was I'm not sure people really are
dying to trade with the Patriots because
you trade someone one of your players he
goes there and plays great and it ended
up looking terribly like the Lions were
probably going to cut Kyle van Noy
and he's become like a really really
solid player and a Patriots historically
awesome defense I don't think I don't
think anybody wants to deal with that
backlash I like how the Dolphins are
getting credit for selling their stock
sooner than like dumping their stock you
know they picked up a key to leave and
like we're crediting the Dolphins for
being front-office tanking here
it's really basketball style tanking and
reality is Sachi Brown who is no longer
in football he sort of sent the
foundation for this by doing this with
Brock Osweiler basically you know it was
16 million dollars for a second round
pick and Brock Osweiler basically was
the was the player that got that got
traded away so basically what the Miami
Dolphins did was they paid four million
dollars for fifth-round Khalid is never
going to play for them he's not even
going to report he's gonna rehab on his
own I mean I you know I don't know
what's gonna happen but I don't think
he's going to be in a Dolphins uniform
when they're like you know two and
twelve or something in December
basically they paid four million dollars
for a fifth-round her they obviously
believe that is worth it they need to
spend money they have spending very
little money against the cab this year
next year some would argue that's not
worth it for a player that may not make
your roster basically it's a four
million dollar lottery tickets to a
player that has a less than 50% chance
to make your Austin is an interesting
gamble Ian thank you for joining us we
appreciate your time all right
always good to talk to you and take care
that's Ian Rapoport NFL Network insider
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]